Transcription: Viji Gowri
Relecteur: eric vautier
L’expérience du monde
passe à travers notre corps.
Il y a très peu de choses
que l’on peut faire sans activer
un ou des mouvements,
volontairement ou involontairement.
Par exemple, présentement je vous parle,
je suis en mouvement.
Vous m’écoutez, vous êtes en mouvement,
ne serait-ce que parce que votre cœur bat
et que vous respirez.
Alors moi, ce qui me fascine,
c’est qu’on sait tous et toutes
qu’on a un corps,
qu’on en a besoin pour vivre.
Et pourtant, dès qu’on rentre
dans le monde de la recherche,
le corps semble s’effacer.
Il est écarté de nos pratiques
de professionnels en recherche.
Car somme toute, nous utilisons
notre corps de manière assez basique.
Soit que nous sommes assis
sept à huit heures par jour
pour traiter des données
ou parler avec nos collègues.
Ou alors, nous l’utilisons
de manière mécanique
pour nous déplacer
d’un point A à un point B.
Nous sommes sans doute aussi
le fruit d’une culture de recherche
qui repose sur deux postulats.
Premier postulat : un chercheur, ça pense.
Et pour ça, pas besoin de corps,
une tête suffit.
Deuxième postulat :
le corps nous induirait en erreur.
Il fausserait nos interprétations
en recherche.
Ou alors il ferait partie
de la sphère personnelle, intime.
Dans tous les cas, le corps est nié.
Ou alors, il est vraiment
négativement valorisé
dans la hiérarchie du savoir.
Il nous empêcherait de raisonner.
Alors, je pose la question :
« Qu’est-ce qui se passe
si on se met à écouter notre corps ?
Qu’est-ce qu’on pourrait
apprendre de lui ? »
Le corps, souvent on le regarde comme
quelque chose d’extérieur à soi,
comme quelque chose
où il faut mettre de l’effort
pour être plus beau, plus fort
ou tout simplement plus conforme
à la société dans laquelle nous vivons.
Mais moi, je ne vous parle pas
de ce corps-là,
je vous parle de notre corps
à tous et à toutes,
de notre corps fait de chair et d’os,
de notre corps organique,
de notre corps sans effort.
Et je vous invite peut-être
à renouer maintenant avec ce corps,
peut-être
en juste prenant un petit souffle…
Ah, je vous vois.
Relâchez les épaules…
Peut-être scannez l’espace pour sentir
qu’il y a des corps autour de vous,
sentir votre dos sur le dossier du siège,
vos jambes, vos extrémités…
Voilà, c’est de ce corps-là dont je parle.
Quelles sont les vertus de ce corps ?
Je ne sais pas si vous l’avez ressenti
avec ce qu’on a fait,
mais le corps, il nous renvoie au présent.
Quand on est dans son corps,
on n’est ni dans le passé,
ni dans le futur.
On est là ici et maintenant.
Le corps, on peut aussi le voir
comme une série de capteurs,
une énorme antenne
émettrice et réceptrice,
qui nous permet de capter des informations
qui viennent de l’extérieur,
les informations extracorporelles,
et qui viennent de l’intérieur,
les informations intracorporelles.
Il y a le corps, mais il y a aussi
le corps en mouvement.
Qu’est-ce qu’il nous apprend,
ce corps en mouvement ?
Le corps en mouvement,
c’est le corps de la communication,
de la relation à l’autre, de la connexion.
Et avec lui, on développe
une habileté extraordinaire
qui s’appelle l’empathie.
C’est-à-dire la capacité
à se mettre à la place de l’autre,
à ressentir ce que ressent l’autre,
sans le juger.
Le corps en mouvement,
c’est aussi un corps d’émotion.
Savez-vous que « se mouvoir » et
« s’émouvoir » ont la même racine latine
qui est « emovere », qui veut dire
« mettre en mouvement » ?
Enfin, le corps en mouvement,
c’est un corps d’action, d’engagement.
Avec le corps vient le désir de faire,
la motivation intrinsèque d’agir.
Le corps est donc ce qui permet
et motive l’action.
Vous allez me dire :
« Oui, tout ça, c’est bien beau,
mais quel rapport avec la recherche ? »
Eh bien, je vous répondrai : « Tout. »
Et pour ça, je voudrais vous
présenter trois expériences
sans entrer dans le détail
pour chacune d’entre elles
qui ont comme point commun
de mobiliser le corps et le mouvement
en recherche.
Première expérience, elle a lieu au MIT,
aux États-Unis, à Boston.
Il s’agit d’un chercheur, Otto Scharmer,
qui travaille avec une artiste,
Madame Hayashi.
Ensemble, ils ont développé une forme
qui s’appelle
Le Théâtre de Présence Sociale.
Ils explorent les questions
de changement social
en mobilisant le corps et le mouvement.
Deuxième expérience, à Paris.
Bruno Latour, sociologue.
Lui, il travaille avec des citoyens
sur les questions d’habitabilité
dans un monde en transition.
Et là encore, il mobilise
le corps et le mouvement
dans son approche
qui mêle art et politique.
Troisième expérience,
ici à l’université de Sherbrooke.
Yeah !
Dans notre laboratoire,
on explore une approche
qu’on a appelé le « Dancestorming »
en référence au « Brainstorming » -
excusez l’anglicisme -
et qui explore les questions d’éthique
dans les projets de recherche
à travers le corps et le mouvement.
Qu’est-ce qu’on a vu dans ces images ?
On a vu des corps debout,
des corps animés, des corps vivants,
des corps en mouvement.
Ces projets,
ils reposent sur trois éléments.
Premier élément, le corps et le mouvement
permettent de produire une connaissance
et un savoir nouveaux.
Souvent, on utilise les artistes
pour illustrer
une connaissance qu’un chercheur
aurait pensé ailleurs.
Eh bien, ici on utilise à la fois
l’art et les chercheurs ensemble.
Deuxième élément, on utilise l’espace
comme un espace symbolique, potentiel,
un espace laboratoire
où on rejoue les projets de recherche
ensemble entre chercheurs.
Et enfin, dans toutes ces approches,
il y a un facilitateur, une personne,
qui encadre le processus,
qui sait lire et faire parler les corps.
Qu’est-ce qu’on apprend
quand on fait ce type d’expérience ?
Pour bien comprendre, imaginons un projet.
Amir, un jeune chercheur
qui étudie la qualité de l’eau
des lacs au Québec.
Amir, il veut expérimenter
le processus avec ses collègues.
Quand il entre dans la pièce,
il est porteur de cette culture
de recherche
qui fait qu’il est distant et détaché
par rapport à son projet de recherche
et aussi qu’il voit les lacs
comme une abstraction
parce qu’il a fallu qu’il découpe
et délimite le processus
pour le rendre étudiable.
Avec Amir et ses collègues,
on va utiliser
les qualités et les vertus du corps,
à savoir l’engagement
dans le temps présent
et l’engagement physique, sensitif,
émotionnel dans le projet de recherche.
Je fais entrer Amir,
ses collègues sont assis autour de lui
et on explore son projet avec lui.
« Tu prélèves de l’eau des lacs
pour faire tes études. »
Je peux éventuellement
lui faire sentir l’eau
très concrètement,
l’ancrer dans la réalité.
J’attends et je pose la question
à Amir et à ses collègues,
« Amir, que ressens-tu
quand tu prélèves de l’eau des lacs ? »
J’attends encore un instant
et je repose la question
à ses collègues et à Amir,
« Que ressens-tu ?
Que ressentez-vous quand vous prélevez
de l’eau des lacs du Québec ? »
Avec ce simple exercice,
Amir peut prendre conscience
de certaines choses.
Déjà, de distant, il se retrouve touché
par son projet de recherche,
de détaché, il se retrouve immergé
dans son projet de recherche
et d’abstrait, le projet, d’un seul coup,
s’ancre dans le réel.
Il retrouve une part de réalité.
Il peut ainsi prendre conscience
par exemple, qu’il n’est pas neutre.
Qu’il le veuille ou non,
il affecte un milieu quand il l’étudie.
Il peut aussi réaliser que
ce sont des lacs de chez nous,
des lacs qui,
si potentiellement ils sont pollués,
pourraient être appelés
à disparaître, à mourir.
Grâce à ce chemin qu’on fait ensemble,
Amir, une fois qu’il sait,
c’est difficile de revenir en arrière,
alors il peut décider d’explorer
autrement son projet de recherche
et par exemple, de faire venir
de nouvelles parties prenantes
comme les populations locales
qui vivent près de lacs
et avec qui il pourrait travailler.
On le voit donc, grâce au corps,
on peut aboutir à des questionnements
qui sont d’ordre éthique et politique
sur ce que l’on est en train de faire,
en tant que chercheurs et chercheuses
avec le monde dans lequel nous habitons.
La connaissance sensible,
incarnée, incorporée,
est une connaissance de la reliance.
Elle nous mène sur le chemin de
ce qui est juste et raisonnable de faire
en (coupure de micro)
Le micro ! Ça y est, il est revenu !
(Rire de soulagement)
La connaissance sensible
incarnée nous mène
sur le chemin de ce qui est
juste et raisonnable de faire
en prise avec le réel, en cohérence
avec les battements de cœur de ce monde.
Alors oui, cela demande du courage,
celui de s’exposer entièrement,
de la tête aux pieds.
Et oui, cela demande de la pédagogie,
celle de reconnaître comme valide
et légitime ce type de connaissance
et d’apprendre à l’apprivoiser.
Pour terminer,
je voudrais vous parler d’Audrey.
Audrey, c’est une personne
réelle qui vit à Paris
que l’ai rencontrée
quand nous avons rédigé avec un collectif,
ce petit livre qui s’appelle
« Rencontre intimes avec l’Anthropocène ».
C’est un collectif de chercheurs
qui s’interrogent sur la question
de l’engagement en recherche
à propos du changement climatique.
Audrey, elle se rend souvent au Bénin.
Elle y collecte des données,
elle prend des témoignages
et tous convergent vers un seul point :
il y a une évolution rapide
des écosystèmes
qui a des conséquences inéluctables
sur les populations, sur les animaux
et sur les paysages.
Je voudrais vous lire ce passage
qui est page 31,
parce que pour moi,
il illustre parfaitement ce qui se passe
quand la connaissance rationnelle,
intellectuelle, s’intègre, s’incarne.
Je vous invite éventuellement à l’écouter
en revenant dans votre corps,
en baissant légèrement les yeux,
en ouvrant grand vos oreilles
et tous vos capteurs sensoriels.
« Ce n’était pourtant pas un scoop.
Ce que je notais, je l’avais déjà lu,
mille fois entendu.
C’était une réalité
qui ne faisait pas de doute pour moi.
Il me semblait avoir déjà pris
connaissance de tous ces faits.
Pourquoi donc avais-je l’impression
de les découvrir pour la première fois ?
Parce qu’ils m’étaient contés
par des personnes bien réelles ;
parce que le désespoir, la souffrance
transparaissaient pour la première fois
derrière les mots,
qui m’étaient communiqués
par le corps tout entier de ces individus
pour venir s’inscrire dans le mien,
dans chacune de mes cellules.
Désormais, je ne pourrai plus oublier. »
Alors oui, s’il vous plait, désormais
faisons en sorte de ne pas oublier.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)